Few actors have been lucky enough to feature in a
universally-acclaimed movie, and fewer still have
appeared in many — but it does happen. From major
movie stars to little-known character performers,
these are the actors who have the most movies
with a 100 percent score on Rotten Tomatoes.
In 1959, Alec Guinness was awarded a knighthood
by Elizabeth II for his contribution to the field
of arts — just in case his Academy Award, his
BAFTA, his star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame,
and his nine perfect movies on Rotten Tomatoes
weren't testament enough to his talent.
Like many other esteemed actors, Alec Guinness
enjoyed working with one particular director.
The British thespian was a preferred collaborator
for the acclaimed director David Lean,
often appearing in his legendary screen
adaptations of Charles Dickens films, such as
Great Expectations and Oliver Twist. Both of these
films are among Guiness' 100% movies, which also
includes two of the darkest comedies ever made
— The Ladykillers and Kind Hearts and Coronets.
Of course, Guinness will forever
be remembered as Obi-Wan Kenobi in
George Lucas' original Star Wars trilogy
— but that movie isn't one of the nine,
boasting an impressive yet
imperfect 92% on Rotten Tomatoes.
"Toto, I've a feeling we're
not in Kansas anymore."
Judy Garland may well be one of the most famous
actresses of all time. Though she's perhaps best
known as Dorothy in 1939's The Wizard of
Oz, which sits at 98% on Rotten Tomatoes,
Garland has appeared in a total of nine films with
a perfect score — including the Christmas classic
Meet Me in St. Louis and other beloved musicals
such as Summer Stock and Till the Clouds Roll By.
Garland is yet another critically renowned star
who took on a new name during her youth, in this
case from Frances Ethel Gumm. While performing
with her siblings as the singing Gumm Sisters,
a fellow performer suggested they change the
name. The Gumm Sisters became the Garland Sisters,
and Judy chose her new first name based on
inspiration from a Hoagy Carmichael song.
Unfortunately, this was just the first
of many demands showbiz would come to
place on Garland. In the end, Garland was
overcome by the pressures of the industry,
the abusive nature of the people she worked with,
and the substance abuse that followed. She
died of an accidental overdose in 1969.
Having been forced to fend for herself at a
very young age, it makes sense that Barbara
Stanwyck would be best known for playing
complex and independent women on screen.
She began working at just 13 years old, first as a
chorus girl, then a nightclub dancer, and finally
with touring companies. She then landed her first
Broadway play in 1926 with The Noose, in which she
played the role of a cabaret dancer. Her leading
role in the 1927 run of Burlesque earned Stanwyck
her first movie offers, marking the beginning of
a long career in Hollywood; one that included such
films as The Lady Eve, which is just one of her
nine films with a 100% rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Stanwyck was one of the most versatile,
adaptable actresses in the history of cinema.
She even changed her name at the alleged
behest of a producer on The Noose,
having been born Ruby Catherine Stevens. Because
she was known for that versatility — rather than
the movie star glamour that was the typical
of female leads at the time — she was often
passed over for actresses like Bette Davis
or Jean Arthur. But none of those stars ever
appeared in more truly great movies than this
self-sufficient queen of stage and screen.
Born Samuel Jones in 1898, the man later
known as Wallace Ford ran away from an
abusive home and joined a vaudeville troupe
traveling through Canada. As a teenager,
he journeyed south by train-hopping to the U.S.
in search of a better life with his friend,
who was actually named Wallace Ford.
Tragically, Ford was run over by a
locomotive, and Jones then took the
name of his dead friend as tribute.
And what a tribute it was. From theater troupes
to Broadway to Hollywood, Ford made a home in
the entertainment industry just as he made a
home in America. He became known as a tough
but friendly and quick-witted comic character,
who starred in over 150 TV series and films,
nine of which were 100% loved by critics.
These included Alfred Hitchcock's Shadow of
a Doubt and the surprisingly dark Jimmy
Stewart Western, The Man from Laramie.
Gary Cooper's characters were often soft-spoken
and stoic, yet always heroic. This unique persona
led the man born as Frank James Cooper to become
a much-loved star in the entertainment industry.
With his iconic drawl and imposing height, Cooper
was the perfect pick for the Western genre,
so it should come as no surprise that titles like
The Westerner, The Virginian, and The Plainsman
are all riding tall in the 100% Rotten Tomatoes
saddle. He also starred in war films such as Beau
Geste and comedies like Ball of Fire, but if
you really want to understand Cooper's charm,
you have to look outside his 100% line-up
— and focus on 1941's Meet John Doe.
In a roundabout way, this movie says the most
about the types of characters Cooper portrayed.
Rather than the elite Hollywood actor
whose star power leaked into every role,
audiences got to know Cooper as
the everyman; the literal John Doe,
who reflected the dreams and aspirations
of the everyday average American.
It makes sense that Humphrey Bogart be
closely associated with the notion of
Hollywood perfection, considering he's the iconic
face of the 1942 film so frequently cited as the
epitome of "good cinema": Casablanca.
In fact, renowned critic Roger Ebert
once suggested Casablanca appears on more "best
films of all time" lists than any other movie.
Surprisingly enough, however, Casablanca scores
99% on Rotten Tomatoes, meaning it doesn't
quite make it into Bogart's 100 Club.
Still, he has an impressive 11
perfect-scoring movies to make up for it.
One of those films, 1941's The Maltese Falcon,
catapulted Bogart to a whole new level of success.
Having slowly worked his way through B-movies
and played supporting roles in bigger flicks,
Bogart was suddenly a leading man — and he'd
soon become known as one of the all-time greats.
It's interesting to note, however, that he
had an exactly equal number of 100%-rated
films before and after The Maltese Falcon,
a testament to the fact that he'd always
been an asset to the productions in which he
featured, whether he was a leading man or not.
"Here's looking at you, kid."
Funnily enough, the legendary actor C. Aubrey
Smith started out as a cricketer — and the
sportsmanlike conduct of the game easily
translated to the gentlemanly characters
he'd become known for in Hollywood. Smith appeared
in 11 perfect-scoring movies during his career,
such as The Four Feathers and And Then There
Were None, and in the majority of them he
portrayed either an aristocrat or a military
officer. Indeed, it seems like Smith never
quite forgot his roots. Even after arriving
in California, he insisted that his English
colleagues all join the Hollywood Cricket Club
— and make a point to show up and play, too.
In addition to being renowned
for the roles he played,
Smith was also famous for his facial hair,
which included a set of bushy eyebrows and
an impressive handlebar mustache. Along with
his cricket obsession, that impressive 'stache
fed back into the persona of the Hollywood
gentleman. And sure, maybe that meant Smith
was a little typecast — but it clearly
served him well during his 34-year career.
From his early beginnings at the Omaha
Community Playhouse, Henry Fonda rose to great
prominence in the entertainment industry — and
eventually played in 11 films that received 100%
approval ratings from critics on Rotten Tomatoes.
He appeared in a number of productions now
regarded as classics, such as The Lady Eve and
the iconic courtroom thriller 12 Angry Men.
His working relationship with John Ford
also produced a good few films with 100%
ratings, including The Grapes of Wrath,
Young Mr. Lincoln, and My Darling Clementine.
Fonda's range was exceptionally wide, not
just in terms of acting ability but in
the projects he featured in, too. In fact,
he's the only actor with a number of 100%
films in the double digits who
also appeared in a film with a
0% approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes:
the much-maligned 1977 movie Tentacles.
But Fonda's legacy is carried by his family as
well as his films. He's the father of decorated
actress and activist Jane Fonda, as well as actor
and director Peter Fonda. His Rotten Tomatoes
profile describes him as having a "benign,
paternal presence," and despite being somewhat
distant as an actual father, he clearly instilled
a genuine love of acting into his children.
Audiences saw the actor and military officer
James Stewart as the embodiment of the ideal
American — something of a nebulous accolade
today, but back then it made him one of the
most popular movie stars around. He was
clearly a hit with the critics, too,
having appeared in a dozen pictures that
are currently 100% favorably reviewed.
The moral rectitude of his early roles may have
been part of what made the moral obscurity of
his later roles all the more striking. Though they
aren't counted among his perfect-scoring pieces,
Stewart starred in a number of legendary Hitchcock
films, often as a far shadier character than
those he was better-known for playing. That's
also true for The Naked Spur, a 100%-scoring
Western that found Stewart playing a
bounty hunter with a serious dark side.
This trend continued with movies such as
The Man from Laramie and Winchester '73,
which cemented Stewart's reputation as one of
the most versatile and popular actors of his era.
One of the most recognizable names
in cinema history also boasts a
whopping 12 movies with a 100% Rotten
Tomatoes score. Marion Robert Morrison,
known professionally by his screen
name John Wayne, is almost synonymous
with the American Western, and he was a
sure-fire box-office hit for many decades.
None of this might ever have happened, however,
if Marion Robert Morrison the football player
hadn't suffered a career-ending injury. With
his sporting dreams dashed, Morrison turned
to Hollywood for his shot at greatness. His very
first leading role was, of course, in a Western:
1930's The Big Trail. But the picture which made
him famous didn't arrive until nine years later.
John Ford's 1939 movie Stagecoach featured Wayne
in the role of the Ringo Kid, and subsequently
made him a household name. Fittingly, both
of these films have earned 100% approval
ratings on Rotten Tomatoes, along with other such
classics as Rio Bravo, Red River, and El Dorado.
Ward Bond has the most 100%-scoring
movies of any actor in history,
which appears to be one of the great
benefits of being a character actor.
Bond didn't often play the lead in his films,
but his status as an indispensable supporting
character led to the record breadth of
his career in universally-beloved films.
As a result, Bond has played in a stunning
15 films with 100% on Rotten Tomatoes,
including The Grapes of Wrath, The Maltese
Falcon, and Young Mr. Lincoln. In particular,
he starred in almost two dozen movies
alongside his former football teammate,
John Wayne, and often worked with preferred
collaborators such as John Ford and Frank Capra.
On top of that, he has appeared in
a number of all-time classics with
slightly less than perfect scores, such
as It's a Wonderful Life and Gone with the
Wind. So while Ward Bond may not have been the
most famous actor to have worked in Hollywood,
it's unlikely anyone will ever quite
manage to match his incredible achievement.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.